Sofia hi hi I heard you have an
imaginary friend I do I do have one
I do have an imaginary friend yes she
was a deer named Erin and we had a plant
in like a house plant in our apartment
when I was a kid and I used to dig up
like the roots of this plant and
immediately blame it on Erin and my
parents like couldn't do anything about
it because they were like we have to let
her have her imaginary friend I think in
my mind she was like Bambi's mom or
sister you and I mean I was like really
upset when Bambi's mom died as a kid so
I had like a connection to like a female
a maternal deer definitely used her as a
scapegoat like a hundred percent hi you
had imaginary friends as a kid or even
till this day Pete was a human it was a
very literal kid so Pete was basically
like my sort of obnoxious little brother
I was the good kid and Pete was the one
who like you know set things on fire
Pete and I hung out a lot I liked
playing him in checkers he was better at
me than in checkers and I realized
quickly that when you play yourself in
checkers the person who goes second kind
of always wins
hi
you want to talk about your imaginary
friend ashore yeah so I had like a few
imaginary friends growing up one that
was probably my favorite was my friend
Ralph he had like a round face and he
had like curly hair and I think he was
always wearing like a blue shirt for
some reason it was cool we would play
games together we actually plotted one
time so I had like I loved the Rugrats
obviously everyone knew that Angelica
was evil
so we plotted to kidnap Angelica he made
me do this
but we duct-taped her her hands together
and duct tape her mouth
my mom told me that I was like cursing
at it but it was Ralph that was cursing
at Angelica he really was like kind of a
violent person and kind of influenced me
to do crazy stuff like that but he was
he was great
Britney Ashley this is your song um I
heard you had an imaginary friends I had
more than just one imaginary friend I
had a whole entire imaginary baseball
team every day after school when I was
in elementary school at a huge back yard
and I would play I would you know curate
my own baseball practice - my whole
invisible baseball team they had names
it was generally this is very sad it was
generally names like kids names that I
wanted to name my children there's a lot
of unisex names
it was great I would say now my
imaginaries friend's name was Dakota
Dakota was a boy he was Orange Dakota
was a little bit of everything when I
was growing up he was a cowboy obviously
um samurai a ninja he's a paleontologist
for a little bit yeah but it wasn't like
a bad influence
he was basically when my friends
couldn't play and had to entertain
myself me and Dakota went on adventures
he's probably a jet fighter now because
that seems like it would be really fun
but you put away childish things and you
become a boring adult and Dakota is
someone else's now